let's go to Justin from Utah Justin from
Utah you know most of our Utah callers
just happen to be Mormons even though I
know Utah is filled with people who
aren't Mormons uh and oftentimes Utah
callers are very interesting welcome
Justin what can I do for you
hi David yeah so I was born LDS I'm no
longer OBS just just for the record okay
um yeah obviously I live in a in a very
red State
um with regard to
um you know the gun control uh debate
and so on I often hear that you know we
need more we need more Heroes right
um versus uh stricter gun control I I
liken that too
if we were able to stop cancer no one
ever suffers from the disease again
right by that logic the best solution is
to
um you know instead hire more doctors
rather than actually cure cancer right I
think that's a very interesting analogy
which is rather than more good guys with
guns to fire back at the bad guys with
guns but make clear by the time the
police get there that they're the good
guy not the bad guys of the police why
don't we just try to reduce the number
of shootings that even start to begin
with I think it's an apt analogy
it's nice thing
anything else today Justin
no I just you know I see that online all
the time
um you know it's it's a common talking
point you know arming teachers it's just
it's ridiculous I I don't understand
where the disconnect is on
on that other side do you do you have
kids Justin
I do would you I mean I don't know what
kind of school they go to but if a
school they went to Armed teachers would
you pull them from the school
I would consider it tell me I mean a lot
of times with these things it's like
easier said than done you know the
logistics can be complicated and then
you've got to move kids who have an
established social group like I'm not
pretending it's easy but it's at least
something you would think about
yeah absolutely I I would have the means
to homeschool if I if I wanted to right
yeah you know it's yeah it's very
troubling though out of curiosity you
said you you're like former LDS are you
no longer a believer in the doctrine or
you are no longer part of an organized
LDS church but you're still sort of like
a believer of the doctrine
I am not a believer in any organized
religion okay
yeah
um
yeah interestingly you know my my mother
would not go to church she would drop us
off
oh is that right yeah at the end of you
know as we got older we would walk in
one door and go out the other and go
hang out for a while okay so interesting
all right my friend listen great to hear
from you appreciate your insights on
your question
take care all right there is Justin from
Utah uh very very interesting to hear
from you